Hey  Youtubers it's Charlie so much new stuff from
Fear The Walking Dead this is good be breakdown
of the new footage is will is what's going
on with the series there's still a bunch of
questions they haven't answered yet avulsive
that a really cool announcement I'll do the
end of the video so here we go so apparently
there's no no big thing to worry about know
Walker virus that's going to take over the
entire world everybody just chill out for
about six months till the Walker ship hits
the fan somebody be sure to check and make
sure that Rex door still locked in the hospital
the person we see in the trailer she's to
one of the main stars that's can Dickens you
probably seen her in at least something before
she shows up all over the place she's on Sons
of Anarchy issues in house of cards have all
the cast members they've announced the show
she's the one that is maybe most excited this
first season is going to be the descendent
the madness so on the timeline of the main
show I've I would say this is sometime maybe
a month or two before rate goes into a coma
Robert Kirkman is always kind of fuzzy about
exact dates but you generally speaking this
takes place while Rick is in a coma remember
he got shot once the hospital when everything
was still fine Rhaesh is say before everyone
knew that something was bad because the virus
is spread over the world almost instantaneously
I would I was that it definitely started before
he went into the coma it is the people didn't
start noticing it because you don't turn into
a walker unless you die it's like a snowball
effect you know where one Walker makes to
walkers those two made for walkers and so
on and so on so all the people you'll meet
in episode one will be in complete denial
the kid to be start running the last promote
we emulate and see what is running from that's
actually that's this characters son she along
with Cliff Curtis are likely the two main
leads they both have families of their own
they the kind of band together is the ship
hits the fan and if any the other promos haven't
made it clear this is taking place in Los
Angeles that the people are here already,
like walkers so if it's really well just a
bunch of really rich zombies just shuffling
around Beverly Hills I feel like this kid
is going to end up being the Lisa Simpson
of the series like the smart person that nobody
listens to that's the curse of being smart
in a post-apocalyptic world is like the smarter
you are the less people will listen to you
but you can't be too hard on them I meet you
member what Carol was like before the apocalypse
now she actually Melissa McBride just won
a Saturn award for the second year in a row
for her betrayal of Carol a lot of you have
been asking you what is this have to do with
the comics Robert Kirkman said that they created
this to be something separate from the comics
the main series is adapted directly from the
comics again they take stories directly from
the comics and turn them into scripts will
for the most part I mean is an adaptation
so the that the change things to fit with
the cast they have the spinoff series is going
to be just a completely different group of
characters than we've seen in the comics there
just like so many other stories you can tell
in The Walking Dead universe but we've been
so localized to Georgia that it's like okay
we we want to go to the other side of the
United States don't counter some of the same
challenges just make completely different
choices is is like choose your own adventure
with walkers the really important stuff though
they've only said that it's going to premier
in August that they haven't said a specific
date yet which is was kind of mysterious usually
they just didn't they say like it's going
to air on X day it's either going to be the
23rd or the 30th they're going to air all
six episodes in season one that's Razo has
six episodes and then like the week after
that the air season six episode one earlier
maybe the same week it is depends on how
they're going to time it, they might take a break summer
in the middle of they might air them consecutively
they're going to be marketing
the ship out of the spinoff series and they
want to dovetail that with the main series
season six isn't going to premiere to that
second week in October it's be the same week
it is every year it's always that second Sunday
but if you member way way back there were
only six episodes of the of the main series
in season one that was just because they wanted
to see have the show gonna do so expensive
to produce that they didn't want to buy like
20 episodes and have it tank obviously that
didn't happen it became super popular it's
more popular gets higher ratings than game
of thrones to give you perspective they have
listed a second season of the spinoff show
but I don't know that that's confirmed yet
but if they do renew it then it would probably
get a full series order so we get 16 episodes
of that to or at least 13 The Walking Dead
is is an exception amongst other and see shows
in that it gives a couple extra episodes per
season just because it's so profitable for
them Robert Kirkman said that the general
ideas is that the timeline of the spinoff
series would catch up with the main show but
this first season is going to tell the story
of the outbreak so why episode six we will
definitely see a ton of walkers chasing people
down but they will be quite is decomposed
is the walkers the main show as members a
whole lot more time is past that's always
the big question the people have it's like
how come there so many Walker still walking
around that they're not eating anybody that's
is not like they gain mass when they eat people
logically you know eventually their organic
tissues which is breakdown till they were
just pure skeletons they just crumpled into
a pile of bones maybe we'll see that we get
The Walking Dead season 17 everyone was wondering
you know how many seasons The Walking Dead
going to go that's also part of the reason
for the spinoff series because it's like they
get maybe like five or six seasons at least
out of that probably seven but the main show
is going to be too expensive to produce by
the time he gets passed season 10 it I have
no idea if it's going to go that long I think
AMCs going to do everything they can to keep
it around but a lot of that will fall on Robert
Kirkman and the producers the unit they think
they can keep writing fresh stories if it's
any indication Robert Kirkman is said that
he won't stop writing the comic book till
people stop buying it which is never's that
means that the TV show will have stories to
adapt indefinitely but I'm really excited
for it to come back there just they're not
a lot of dramas that match the level of game
of thrones WTF use it try to have like a couple
shows to balance out my week you know shows
that are little bit lighter little bit funnier
than you have like the crazier stuff like
game of thrones and walking dead yet the whole
spectrum of WTF really if the task of the
spinoff series to be just is thrilling as
The Walking Dead without going straight to
walkers although I don't think they would've
pitch the series if there wasn't going to
be a walker like something identifiable as
The Walking Dead by the end of that first
episode. My big question for you guys do you
think that they're going to have like a child
a little girl Walker like they did in
the first episode of The Walking Dead series
were Andrew Lincoln goes up it ends up having
to kill that little girl Kim dickens just
sees some little girl the middle the road
and she has to run over with her car or something
crazy what's going to happen at comic con is they're
actually bringing both shows they're doing
a two hour panel I don't know what kind
of footage they're going to air whatever it
is I'll do video for it also post the panels
so will be good the way the schedule is breaking
down comic con right now it seems like it's going
to be a lighter year than last year there
just like a couple big film companies like
Marvel Paramount Sony that aren't going there
couple big TV panel that aren't happening
because shows haven't started shooting new
footage yet so there are a lot of trailers
to be shown somehow I think him and to wind
up standing in a bunch of lines anyway though
if you've never been to, con it's a lot of
standing in line but is still a lot of fun
it's kind like being a walker you got you
got a like experience the herd at least once
in your life book, con a general can be kind
of a should show if you're not prepared for
so it's can happen is is big because there's
a bunch of other walking dead season six stuff
him and to do a separate video for that is
all posted next on Saturday there were a couple
other videos that I announce the Supergirl
trailer just posted if you haven't seen that
just just watch that and it explain some of
the next videos I maybe working on and I've
also been posting to my game channel recently
to so if you don't about the game channel
there's a link for that in the description
so big announcement after get through, con
I'm a to be working with sky bounded try and
find something really cool to do with you
guys it might be a giveaway might be something
else as long as aren't any contracts that
prevent me from telling you guys about it
ahead of time I will be sure to keep you guys
updated I'm also actually trying to do the
same thing for game of thrones although HBO
doesn't handle all the merchandising first
song of ice and fire like Random House does
the books of me this is a bunch of stuff so
for the giveaways that I do every week will
start getting cooler and cooler that is definitely
the goal what good is a giant YouTube channel
if you can give a bunch of really awesome
free should away server get new walking dead
season six stuff coming next that would be
Saturday morning depending on where you guys
live I'm on Pacific time white is way for
that you can click here for the last walking
dead trailer and you can click here for my
game of thrones Q&A from this week thank you
so much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow